men's dating standards and men's [__]
standards are two entirely different
requests for women they tend to be more
I've seen a lot of guys that will post
and [__] they're like I can't find any
girl I don't know what's going on I
think I look below average and it's like
a 6-2 guy that's got really broad
shoulders he looks really good his hair
is like bro you look fine and there's a
lot of these guys they don't know how to
talk to people and dude I see guys that
are [__] beautiful and they're like
yeah I know girl's gonna talk to me
because I'm only 5 11 and it's like
that's cow if you're 5 11 you're not
losing chicks because you're not tall
enough because you don't have the one
extra inch